in the summer of 2019 the United States
put Silicon Valley in its crosshairs
only a very small number the nearly two
billion apps in the App Store are made
by Apple we have rolled out many
innovations over the course of the
history of our product for every three
dollars of advertising spent online a
business would have to spend an
equivalent of five dollars offline to
get equal prominence that is it a
tremendous savings for the US economy to
some these hearings recall another major
antitrust case a showdown between the
Justice Department and Microsoft the
year was 1998
Microsoft controlled more than 90
percent of the PC operating systems
market at the heart of the case was a
new product the Internet Explorer web
browser prosecutors argued that
Microsoft used its market power to
stifle the growth of competing browsers
at the time many computer networks
relied on software from Microsoft
this gave the firm lots of power and
influence today leaders from Facebook
Amazon Google and Apple are studying big
cases like Microsoft to prepare for
their scrutiny here's what they could
learn from watching Microsoft's case
lesson number one how not to counter an
antitrust probe ahead of the trial the
Justice Department deposed Microsoft's
CEO Bill Gates mr. gates
when did you first become concerned
about the competitive threat that
Netscape posed to Microsoft
Bill Gates behavior his body language is
contemptuous the product that didn't
include Internet Explorer is called the
Windows 95
upgrade arrogant the full breadth of
your question and evasive the Department
of Justice played pieces of that video
in its opening statement to the judge on
the first day of the case and the judge
later said Microsoft you lost me on day
one Gates was deposed well after the
government sounded an alarm over his
company's behavior in 1995 Microsoft was
served a court order for its
anti-competitive activities in software
licensing another case opened after the
Department of Justice argued that
Microsoft violated that court order the
repeat violations and Gates's behavior
did not play well with the judge
presiding over the case after viewing
the tape Judge Thomas Penfield Jackson
expressed negative opinions of gates and
Microsoft to journalists in his decision
he called for Microsoft to be broken up
but on appeal a panel faulted the
judge's conduct as well as some of his
conclusions it threw out parts of the
ruling Microsoft narrowly escaped a
breakup in the aftermath the two sides
agreed to settle with some changes to
how the software maker did business
according to kvass ik The Legend of the
gates tape haunts today's tech reps when
they testify before Congress I think the
approach that especially the the tech
leaders have been have been urged to
take is humility with their inside and
outside lawyers will tell them because
this is deadly serious and if you don't
take this very seriously you expose
yourself your company everything you've
done to real hazard and if you don't
believe us watch this one precedent
number two free doesn't always mean
better for consumers at the heart of any
antitrust investigation lies the
standard of consumer harm
three key elements price quality
innovation that improves business
performance of the long-term for the
benefit of consumers these three factors
have been interpreted by the courts for
decades in the modern era courts have
spent the most time grappling with the
price dimension of harm in Microsoft
Internet Explorer was bundled with
Windows 98 at no charge which meant that
the case would require a different kind
of analysis in the view of the courts
Microsoft made its browser free but
still abused its market power by
favoring its products and shutting out
rivals the government's theory was that
those steps taken to forestall the
emergence of an alternative to the
Windows operating system was improper
exclusion and for the most part the
district court and the Court of Appeals
agreed which means that companies can
harm consumers even if the products
they're offering are free that's
important because in today's digital
economy free is in you don't pay money
to use Google search maps or Translate
but you do pay something of value access
to your personal data certainly in the
modern tech environment an important
dimension of quality is what they do
with your data the treatment of privacy
is a variable of quality that the
consumer is increasingly concerned about
precedent number three the US government
isn't the only test an array of state
attorneys general submitted comments to
the FTC on big tech antitrust violations
they recommend that the department move
its philosophy away from under
enforcement many from that group are
expected to launch their own
investigations across the pond the
European Union already has fined Google
eight billion euro European regulators
also opened new investigations into
Facebook and Amazon in its day
Microsoft also had to defend against a
variety of challengers in 1998 20 state
attorneys general joined the Justice
Department ensuing the tech giant and in
the 2000s Europe's antitrust Commission
launched two investigations into
you're soft those resulted in 1.6
billion euro and fines against the
company I think one needs to put it into
context Microsoft makes profits of about
1.5 billion dollars per month it's not
all that large of I'm neither
competitors nor consumers of Microsoft
are out after finds finds don't really
do them any good its competition that
does them good but we'd rather have
compliance and competition and fines
according to kvass ik the European Union
has broader criteria on which to bring
an antitrust case the --use position in
dealing with high-tech companies leading
firms has been much stronger than the
u.s. they arguably came out with us
stronger remedy than the u.s. did and
their Microsoft case if you ask which
jurisdiction plays the leading role in
setting global standards and influencing
the way that other countries think about
competition law it's unmistakably the
European Commission
all told Microsoft's tangle with
antitrust law stretched from 1995 to
2011 in Silicon Valley that's a lifetime
according to kvass ik you can expect the
tech companies to argue that a lot will
change in their sector as the government
attempts to make a case one thing that
the companies will argue is let's take
account for a second of how we got here
where was Google in 1998 where was
Facebook didn't exist that's years later
where was the Amazon another nascent
Enterprise with an interesting idea in
the final years of Microsoft's case the
Windows operating system that Microsoft
fought so hard to protect lost ground to
the pantheon of web-based applications
that we enjoy right now today the
operating system commands only a 35
percent market share meanwhile Internet
Explorer enjoyed a dominant share of the
web browser market through 2012 but
eventually a new browser Google Chrome
overtook Explorer how the Justice
Department presides over these
investigations just might cause another
shake-up for come
he's on charts like this
[Music]